[Music]
kim kardashian totally eats it
wakeboarding on vacation that was really
funny
on monday the kkw beauty founder took to
instagram to share a sneak peek at her
family getaway
which included a little fun out on the
water
okay so kim totally wiped out but a for
effort kim
a for effort my advice would be
go for it and honestly it's the scream
for me
but in true kim k spirit the 40 year old
reality star dusted herself off
and tried again and seriously nailed it
i mean she looks like a pro it was a lot
of fun
as for her preferred wakeboarding music
[Music]
yeah celine dion thank you
but according to kim her sister chloe
wasn't exactly loving it
isn't that crazy kim also shared some
cute clips having fun on a giant water
slide
the mom of four took a ride down and
here's her son
saint pushing his little sister chicago
down
kim captioned the clip just when i
thought saint was being nice
along with a face palm emoji
and it appears kim's sis kylie jenner
was also there the kylie cosmetics
founder hit up her insta story to share
this snap of her three-year-old daughter
stormi
playing with her cousin chicago and this
sweet daddy-daughter pic
with travis scott and their little girl
of course this low-key getaway comes
just
days after kim slayed her italian
vacation in rome
rocking some chic ensembles while
touring the vatican
the coliseum and the trevi fountain at
the end of the day life is about being
happy
being who you are a source recently told
et
that kim is feeling really confident
since filing for divorce from kanye west
after six years of marriage in february
but the source adds that the situation
between kim and kanye is still pretty
emotional
and not fully resolved so it's been hard
to completely close this chapter
and according to the source kim has been
spending a ton of time with their four
children
having kids is just there's no way to
describe it but it's a lot
quote kim is really going out of her way
to make sure the kids are preoccupied
at all times ensuring that they are busy
and keeping them living in the moment
kim can get overwhelmed at times but she
really has a handle on juggling so much
with the kids and work as of late
she's feeling really confident and
continually having the support of her
family and
loved ones has been game changing for
[Music]
her